Why he was barbecued.
That's where I started to believe secondhand smoke is a real thing.
It's fucking,
yeah.
I didn't think it was until then.
People that don't think it's real.
It's great.
When we used to mock tape,
cause take didn't want to get high,
we would just smoke pot and Tate would have to stick his head out the window
like an ostrich.
Like what the fuck?
He was worried and you want to get hotbox and that's when we used to get vans.
Remember we used to get vans for awhile?
Conversion vans.
Yeah.
We would rent vans because it was so many of us would come.
Yeah,
we would entourage it.
Red Redman would film it.
We would just have shenanigans and every town we went to
you of course.
And then Eddie Tate and red band as the non comedians and then me and Dunkin or
me and Diaz or whatever.
Um,
there was a shitload of us.
Yeah.
So fuck six people and then we would feast.
We'd go to these fucking amazing restaurants.
Fogo a lot.
We went to a lot of photos.
It brings me back to one of my memories.
I believe it was Cincinnati was nearby right near the hotel.
Do you want US Korea?
Yeah,
right across the street.
as relieving fucking newly a botox.
When I came in,
I'm like,
dude,
that's fucking Vandelay and he was,
he was the most fierce pregame fighter.
The way he'd look at you like,
I want to kill you.
Protecting this flight.
Nobody was scary than him in his prime cro.
Cop was scary because he would just be so calm like I don't care,
let's do this.
Cop stared him down more than anybody ever stared Vandelay town.
He wouldn't break.
It could well have cro.
Cop was a straight up killer.
Croatia,
Croatian antiterrorist squad.
They begged for mercy and I've showed them and he's a world class kickboxer like
he wasn't afraid of Vandelay strike and he was a heavyweight and Vandelay really
wasn't a heavyweight.
But anyway,
we saw him checking in,
then we went to eat.
He was in that true husker Rhea 15 minutes late.
Like he threw his shit down and came in.
They were like so excited about,
look,
look at Cro cop.
Wow
Dude,
nobody's stared down cro cop back then that was when cro cop was at the peak.
It was Japanese got going through his routine and he's like fuck.
And I'm pretty sure was before,
uh,
Cro cop really had sort of mastered MMA.
He was coming over as a straight kickboxer and they had different rules for him.
The rules for Cro cop where like you can only fight on the ground for like 30
seconds.
They had like,
yeah.
And if the fight went to a distance it would be a draw.
Yeah,
because he really didn't have a lot of experience with take down defense or any
MMA fighting back then.
And the,
I didn't get botox.
He had his face reconstructed cause his nose,
he had been in so many brawls,
his nose had completely flattened.
We couldn't breathe out of it and he had so much scar tissue over his eyes that
his eyes were drooping down so he'd get cut instantly.
Any,
any punched him,
it hit him,
would open them up like a gas.
And he and his nose was completely flatch.
So they took a chunk of his rib and rebuilt his nose and he had his nose built
big so he could breathe out of it more.
And then he had all the scar tissue from his eyebrows and then pull back.
And according to Dana,
I dunno,
but then it was like he got it done in Brazil on the cheap and it just like
wasn't,
it didn't,
they didn't really make them look like Vander.
Wow.
So he went from Vandelay Silva.
It's like Vandelay Silva has the most profound facial form change in all of MMA
because he went from pretty,
if go back [inaudible] Silva Vandelay Silva versus go to Vandelay Silva versus
Dan Henderson one.
When they first fought in pride,
he,
he was a normal,
actually pretty good looking guy,
like regular good looking guy.
And then by the time he left pride,
his face was just smashed in.
By the time he fought chocolate Dell,
his face was just smashed and his nose had been literally flattened.
Wow.
For from punches and kicks and not just from fights,
but also from training.
The training that he did it shoot to box and Cora Tiba was fucked up.
Fucked up.
That also okay would bring me to another thing.
We got to go to Brazil one time.
We didn't do a show that time,
but that's him versus Dan Henderson could make that a little bigger so you can
see.
Yeah,
super normal kid.
Just a normal looking bad ass.
That was the first fight we fought.
Dan Henderson Chin looks like as it's drawn on dies.
Somebody fucked up
bone.
Yeah,
Jay Leno and hymns,
that picture of annually above that with the eye all fucked up.
That was him from that fight.
Oh really?
And Henderson connected with a haymaker of a right hand and fucked up his eyes.
Smile on that.
Like look at this bad.
Look at this cool picture on by the tick.
But do you mean look at vandelays face there in comparison to his face later on
his career?
Totally different.
Dan Henderson looks exactly the same.
He looks like the same guy.
He's just an other version.
He might be one of the toughest guys ever lived.
So tough.
Yeah.
Dan is just a fucking little that picture up there with the tattoos and the
shoulders go to that one.
Now that's him after facial reconstruction,
make that larger c that's after the facial reconstruction is settled in,
you know.
Oh we saw him right then and he just fought real recently.
A couple of weeks ago.
He's still fighting gun knocked out by rampage.
Rampage flatlined them.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pay Just so fun to,
Yup.
Rampage still carries that power.
That was when he KOD rampage Kao to him in the UFC with him through the ring,
through the rain.
Pride was one of the coolest.
Yeah,
I saw that later.
I mean I,
you know,
way later you come to the UFC and it's like all these highlights,
this backlog of highlights of MMA,
especially if the UFC purchase price.
Yeah.
Rio was really cool.
That's a place to go.
And actually that fight that in terms of the audience response,
the two biggest ones were Sylvia couture in Columbus.
First time they'd ever been in Columbus.
And that real fight Joseph Aldo versus uh,
that was a Chad Mendez,
right?
Which one?
The one in Brazil,
wasn't it?
It was a spinning back kick.
Oh,
that was Terry.
Adam versus a Edson Barboza dude from d from fight,
one of the undercard the place was so that you could feel it shaking.
And I remember them chanting something in the crowd cause Dana did smart.
It's one of the first foreign ones and he made a Brazilian fighter on every,
on every fight.
He fucked up a little by having a couple of times Brazilian versus Brazilian,
but at every fight and they were chanting something in the audience.
Yeah.
You were like,
you were able to the translator,
like,
what are they saying you're going to die?
It was like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They didn't play games,
man.
Oh my God.
That's when they were like legit.
And I believed it.
Like we've got to figure out how we're gonna get Chelsea on and out of here.
Fights Anderson here.
And I'm like,
come on.
And then you go there,
you're like,
oh,
I believe it now.
Yeah.
Well,
they're fiercely,
fiercely nationalistic.